un
après midi de juillet à gendrey dans le
jura
c'est sympa et c'est tous les ans
mi-juillet comme ça les pieds dans la
terre au milieu des chevaux de trait
comtois justin dray dont son élément
bonjour
c'est à la toute jeune député lr a
choisi un canton rural de sa
circonscription pour faire ses premiers
pas
de première de chaque section
à 32 ans
justine gruet prend la suite du député
jean marie sermier après quatre mandats
il a décidé de lui passer la main
facile de passer d'une génération par
l'amour des chevaux
cet évènement qu'est ce que vus comme la
députée ou comme le député les gens ils
savent un peu quelqu'un à bayonne ancien
député et puis à la députée actuelle et
tout le monde le sait il n'ya pas photo
là dessus c'est important quand on fait
ses premiers pas d'avoir aussi
l'expérience de son prédécesseur alors
non pas que pour tenir jonquilles comme
il faut mais aussi dans la passation des
dossiers
la connaissance du terrain la
connaissance des élus aussi je m'occupe
de à l'aise en circonscription
elle va à présent devoir faire ses
preuves au palais bourbon
l'assemblée compte ainsi 300 de nouveaux
visages
des hommes et des femmes qui vont
réaliser leur premier mandat de député
entrez dans la peau d'un parlementaire
première chose il ya le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale qui sera au
combien utile je pense dans les
prochaines semaines vu la composition
nouvelle de cette assemblée thomas
ménagers est devenu député rassemblement
national du loiret
frédéric valletoux élus ont seine et
marne fait ses premiers pas dans le
nouveau parti horizon fois dans
l'émission et puis premier vote sa
famille avec la présidence a fait
beaucoup trop bien mais ça va on aussi
baisse du bétail pendant quelques
semaines quand même pour les obtenir ses
premières dents suis content
venus du jura
et enfin découvrir mon bureau on va
pouvoir s'installer juste une grue et
siègera sur les bancs des républicains
et antoine le moment est lui en essonne
fait son entrée de député dans le groupe
des insoumis important aujourd'hui la
première fois en séance publique ouais
c'est un peu émouvant et on arrive par
la grande porte on va faire notre entier
va falloir regarder les amis c'est en
anglais
[Musique]
ces quatre nouveaux députés deux bords
politiques différents ont accepté que
nous les suivions dans leur premier part
à l'assemblée nationale
loin du loiret c'est un trajet en métro
pas comme les autres pour thomas ménagé
ce matin et le jeune trentenaire est
déjà très concentré sur sa nouvelle
mission
c'est une nouvelle vie qui commence
aujourd'hui donc c'est un moment rempli
d'émotions en quelques minutes je vais
faire mes premiers pas à 30 ans moi fils
d'artisan mes parents n'ont pas le bac
c'est une grande fierté pour ma famille
aussi une grande responsabilité
de se dire qu'on portera pendant et je
vais porter dans cinq ans un 177e part
de notre pays c'est ultra enthousiasmant
le nouveau député s'est fait une petite
notoriété en battant l'ex-ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
aujourd'hui il fait son entrée
officielle au palais bourbon
[Musique]
ouais on y est semble-t-il avec beaucoup
d'émotion on va voir comment tout va se
passer mais c'est un moment voilà
voilà qui touche aux tripes clairement
un moment très émouvant je pense à mes
parents
thomas ménagers
est l'un des 89 députés rassemblement
national
du jamais vu à l'assemblée les candidats
fraîchement élus ont encore du mal à
réaliser
oui
on essaie ça
même marine le pen n'en revient pas et
bien je vous invite à rentrer
comme une maîtresse de maison qui reçoit
chez elle elle accueille un à un les
nouveaux députés
félicitations
des quelques frissons quand même enfin
la
cct fait il ya des bons à rien même pas
de mots en fête
s'il ya un plan de table sais pas
comment on fait
le jeune élu va maintenant devoir se
faire une place et j'ai 30 ans je veux
être un député qui sortent un petit peu
l'écart dans sa manière de travailler
depuis des années on avait des députés
un peu plus mobiles qui
voter un peu bêtement si vous me
permettez l'expression des projets là ce
ne sera pas possible ce qui est
président maintenant on n'a pas la
majorité absolue
[Applaudissements]
dans l'hémicycle les 89 députés rn
triomphe alors que le palais bourbon
vite un séisme politique
[Applaudissements]
la veille
c'est la nuque qui jouait son arrivée
groupée
au premier rang sur la photo antoine les
au mans le nouveau député un sou ni de
l'essonne
il savoure le moment mais à moitié on
est des camarades qui ont traversé
tellement d'étapes tellement difficile
que aujourd'hui c'est ouais c'est un
moment un peu heureux mais un moment qui
est marquée aussi par une très forte
progression du rassemblement national à
l'assemblée nationale et
et pour nous c'est quand même quelque
chose de marquant quoi salle hugot enfin
laissé de répit tu vas bien bravo merci
si
le groupe est l'effet passe de 17 à 75
députés
merci et les anciens ne sont pas
mécontents de voir arriver du renfort
des dizaines d'hommes pendant cinq ans
alors on a ramé on a essayé de
construire des choses mais là degré
d'énergie nom c'est très émouvant
cette émotion le nouvel élu ventron de
conscience en faisant ses premiers pas
dans l'hémicycle
[Musique]
très impressionnant quand on le regarde
à la télévision et quand on voit à
distance fait c'est très
intime où on fait tenir 177 personnes là
dedans mais c'est
serré
et on comprend pourquoi quand il ya des
débats parlementaires les gens peuvent
s'activer sans parler d'un bout à
l'autre de l'hémicycle on s'entend quoi
donc j'ai un patron comme en cela à
partir de politique dans l'hémicycle
pour lui le combat politique se jouera
sur l'un de ses sièges des bancs de la
gauche
[Musique]
mais il ya quand même dans le temps dans
le final il ya quand même léon blum jean
jaurès alors je ne sais pas si
stratégiquement il vaut mieux être en
bas ou euros pour que la voix porte
en dehors des micros
je vais demander ça pour ça je vais
demander des conseils à jean luc
peut-être je dire alors jean luc maes
whaou
les places seront attribuées plus tard
c'est le groupe qui choisira
[Musique]
le premier jour à l'assemblée il ya un
rituel un passage obligé pour chaque
nouvel élu le parcours d'accueil du
député
frédéric valletoux suit les étapes en
élève studieux
la photo du rejet peu plus inquiet sur
l'âge et on a tous fait la main tout
fraîchement registre c'est formidable
j'existe à 56 ans le maire de
fontainebleau se présentait pour la
troisième fois aux législatives
celle ci aura été la bonne il a le droit
à sa mallette de députés classique le
charger la même comme l'air
non surtout pas séparation par ces bleus
au col pour les mères et rouges aux
colts en parle à mon père je connais
bien le protocole même si
j'avais été parlementaire jusqu'à
présent mais je connais quand même un
protocole
et le parcours se poursuit dans le
studio photo de l'assemblée nationale
spécialement aménagé pour l'occasion
[Musique]
jouer j'ai déjà donc je n'aime pas gérer
vous à me dire parce que c'était
formidable superbe saison
mais convaincu la joie de vivre l'avenir
est radieux de toute façon moi je ne
doute pas un instant super on va
regarder voir si nous avons aussi de
tomber d'accord sauf ailleurs lorsqu'on
l'a sourire franc
assez vous êtes souriant
vous l'effet voulu pour les environs
ce sera sa photo officielle de député
voilà nos pages dont je viens de
comprendre que c'est le sésame pour
entrer sortir aller et venir et même
pignon restaurant
non je fais tu allais à la machine à
café me faire un café
mais le café attendra frédéric valletoux
a rendez vous pour la photo du tout
nouveau groupe horizon le jeune parti
fondé par un certain edouard philippe
qui ce jour là se prend même au jeu du
photographe
c'est important qu'ils viennent parce
que c'est un état d'esprit qui doit être
façonnées qu'il doit se façonner la en
ce début de mandat et puis pour ceux qui
arrivent à l'assemblée nationale je peux
dire c'est rassurant parce qu'on a pas
besoin de ça non plus mais on se sont
accompagnés
voilà donc puis ces marques d'attention
aussi vis-à-vis de 30 31 députés
consommer
deux fois plus nombreux les républicains
ont sauvé les meubles avec 62 députés et
une nouvelle génération de
parlementaires parmi eux justin gruet
les lieux du jura que nous retrouvons
dans les jardins de l'assemblée
il ya quand même un changement de vie
puisque j'étais kinésithérapeute de
profession ce qui me permettait d'avoir
mon mandat d'adjointe en plus de la
profession là le mandat de député
nécessairement demande de mettre entre
parenthèses ma vie professionnelle et
puis je crois que pas à pas je vais
aussi prendre une marque
arrivé à me poser sur des convictions
que j'ai en moi et je pense avoir été
élu pour ça pour représenter les
jurassiens représentait aussi une
nouvelle génération politique
la députée jurassienne passera la moitié
de la semaine ici à l'assemblée à 400 km
de sa circonscription
elle découvre son nouveau bureau en
réalité son logement de fonction
ou bien je le pensais que ce serait beau
si grand que ça
donc à priori à deux bureaux et puis je
pense que c'est ici que je pourrais vous
travaillez elle a obtenu une place aux
soins est basse et très bien fait très
bien une annexe du palais bourbon qui a
un avantage certains bureaux ont inclus
je vais essayer de regarder comment
marche le fonctionnement du lit des
salaires plutôt pratique dans tous les
cas
très entendu certains collègues me dire
moi je peux pas dormir dans mon bureau
j'ai besoin de couper
moi je suis là deux à trois jours par
semaine donc la coupure je la ferais
autrement qu'en fin quand je suis sur
paris c'est quand même essentiellement
pour travailler et la proximité entre le
palais bourbon et mon bureau de pouvoir
dormir toujours au même endroit avec mes
affaires ça va quand même être beaucoup
plus pratique
à peine installée elle veut se
familiariser avec les lieux alors là
c'est un local technique
découvrir ses nouveaux voisins
emmanuel maquet
voisin de gauche
je ne sais pas encore
et ça c'est un local d'entretien et
belges devraient être quatre du coup
s'il y a deux locaux techniques et un
voisin de kruth j'ai laissé les clefs
dedans
[Musique]
erreur de débutante
et j'ai daisy mon portable dedans oui jb
alignement d'accueil
et bah ça vous voyez je pensais pas
avoir à le faire
[Musique]
première séance publique pour les
nouveaux députés
moment solennel
voilà on sent la république on sent le
poids de l'histoire on sent le poids des
institutions
donc oui c'est
la séance sera présidée par le député le
plus ancien c'est la tradition et pour
la première fois c'est un député
rassemblement national josé gonzalez je
déclare ouverte la 16e législature de
l'assemblée nationale
un hémicycle plein à craquer mais les
députés tout juste élu ne siège pas
encore par groupe politique
alphabétique
au delà des toutes nos divergences est
un symbole d'unité française je vous
remercie
un symbole pas vraiment du goût
d'antoine les au mans j'étais pas très
très loin de le pen vous avez changent
avec le pen annonceurs je ne change pas
trop avec eux les fachos mai
mais eux ils échangent et bien entre eux
ils étaient 2 de fachos côte à côte
comme ça ils avaient l'air très content
d'être kotaku donc voilà mais non moi
j'étais un peu tout seul j'avais pas de
pas d'amis vraiment je dois dire que
j'étais particulièrement bien placée du
fait de mon nom de famille puisque
j'étais en plein milieu que ce soit en
haut ou en bas à droite la gauche je
sais que cela évoluera n'est en tous les
cas pour la première séance c'était
assez rigolo monsieur ménagé aujourd'hui
pas de texte à adopter monsieur aumont
monsieur valent tous les députés votent
pour la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale
madame yaël brand privé ayant obtenu la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
jeu là proclame présidente de
l'assemblée nationale
c'est historique pour la première fois
une femme est élue au perchoir
contente de voir une femme accéder à ce
poste-là de ce conte c'est vrai qu'elle
a pris le temps de reprendre
l'historique un petit peu de la place
des femmes relation
lionel
le premier débat en séance ce sera dans
quelques jours avec le texte sur la
sécurité sanitaire la lutte contre la
copie de 19
la séance est levée merci
[Musique]
sur le terrain les députés vont devoir
s'entourer choisir leurs collaborateurs
parlementaires
simon goldblatt justement a passé cinq
ans avec un député battu aux dernières
élections
frédéric valletoux l'a repéré c'est leur
première rencontre
à la j'ai rendez vous avec j'espère un
futur collaborateur parce qu'il faut
aussi constituer l'équipe je suis allé
chercher mon courrier à tous à regarder
et puis je vais et je me bats là avec
mon bureau puisque j'ai pas de bureau ou
encore donc là pour l'instant voilà
j'emmène ma maison sur le dos je suis le
député escargots
sa décision fava bon simon et frédéric
valletoux donc que quelques jours pour
faire connaissance
moi j'ai besoin de votre expérience et
de votre savoir et de tout ce que vous
avez appris avec pierre-yves parce que
j'ai pas l'habitude et des relents de
toute la logistique parlementaire le
fonctionnement et les passages obligés
quand on est député
votre cv montrent que vous avez fait
tout ça déjà donc ça m'intéresse moi le
parcours politique de sur elle tous nous
parle donc de toute façon pour moi ça a
été assez rapide après chacun va à son
rythme et c'est vrai que la législature
le temps de la transition entre
législature va généralement très très
vite bonal à mathilde et rapidement il
faut initier le nouveau député au rythme
de l'assemblée
chaque commission de qu'une seule
réunion par semaine
sauf se ferait deux missions d'enquêté
tout chose comme ça dans cette
commission de la présence comme
il a déjà des habitudes de travail et
c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi je
veux aussi il est tout jeune mais c'est
lui qui va me transférer son expérience
vous voyez ça marche dans les deux sens
où et j'apporte j'apporte une aide et
après aussi je m'adapte aussi à ce qu'il
souhaite descendre et à son territoire
aussi parce que chaque député élu d'une
circonscription et donc il faut
s'adapter également à la circonscription
de réalité du quel est ton sur lequel
est élu député
dans quelques instants notre tgv lyria
arrivera en gare de dole ville et nous
vous souhaitons une bonne journée
retour à dole dans sa circonscription du
jura pour justine gruet
et le depuis huit ans à la mairie elle
est déjà bien implanté sur le territoire
bonjour vous allez bien
alors comme chaque samedi jour de marché
la députée ne change pas ses habitudes
elle part à la rencontre des jurassiens
[Musique]
être assez intensif même où on le savait
enfin j'étais préparée
en général je suis deux trois jours sur
paris mais le reste en circonscription
bonjour aujourd'hui elle prospecte aussi
dans le centre ville bonjour y installer
sa future permanence prochain idéalement
j'aimerais bien que ce soit au coeur de
ville à proximité de la mairie puisque
je reste conseillère municipale de la
ville de dole donc ça me permettra
d'avoir un lien de proximité avec
l'équipe municipale les vraiment avec
cette notion de la porte est ouverte à
tous les administrés à tous les élus
locaux donc c'est en cours de
concrétisation et puis à la rentrée on
sera complètement opérationnel
en attendant les réunions se font au
café bonjour
l'équipe parlementaire peaufine l'agenda
de la semaine
je vais à l'amour biffle est de salins
les bains oui à 19 cernier
il est ravi
mais justin gruet prépare surtout ses
prochaines interventions sur le pouvoir
d'achat
sera au parlement dans quelques jours
j'ai cosigné quelques amendements de mes
collègues pour
rédiger ses premiers amendements elle
peut compter sur les conseils de laurent
bourguignat il a travaillé sept ans aux
côtés de son prédécesseur
nous on peut être utile c'est
effectivement lui expliquer qu'on ne
peut pas s'occuper de tous les textes à
l'assemblée nationale tout de suite tout
le temps et qu'il faut choisir ses
thématiques et en fait quand on arrive
en commission il ya un texte qu'on est
utile j'ai vu que les collègues avaient
déposé beaucoup d'amendements et je me
suis dit bah mince et en fait il faut
prendre le temps aussi de se poser et
c'est intéressant de discuter avec
laurent par rapport c'est rassurant en
fait il me dit mais c'est normal tu
viens d'arriver alors si ça veut dire la
caméra qu un certain nombre de
techniques qui refoule ce qu'ils avaient
préparées dans la précédente législature
sebok par définition justin n'en avaient
pas en ce qu on pourrait s'amuser
lui mais seulement ils m'aiment pas trop
l'esprit coll
oui
au palais bourbon le baptême du feu
débute pour les nouveaux élus
chacun travaille dans une des huit
commissions de l'assemblée oui c'est un
moment important parce qu'il peut encore
enfants faire du concret il peut enfin
être utile on peut enfin faire remonter
ce qu'on nous a dit sur le terrain
thomas ménagers a obtenu la prestigieuse
commission des lois premier texte
ménages et les outils de gestion de la
crise sanitaire
avec son groupe le député et rennes
s'oppose au retour du passo frontières
méfiance légitime de nombreux français
sur la gestion de la crise sanitaire
nécessite aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de
transparence notamment quand il s'agit
de mesures qui portent atteinte à nos
libertés fondamentales et qui crée de
plus avec ses interventions thomas
ménagers a marqué des points auprès de
son groupe il a été nommé co porte
parole
il fait partie de cette nouvelle
génération sur laquelle le rassemblement
national mise pour espérer gagner en
respectabilité
les plus anciens et mystiquement verront
peut-être avec en dix ans dans quelques
années il aura il sera assis sur ses
idéaux moi je veux pas m'asseoir sur mes
idéaux je pense vraiment que les
habitants de la circonscription ils
m'ont élu pour faire du boulot pour
avoir des résultats pour montrer une
bonne image sérieuses constructives
antoine les au mans gagne
progressivement en assurances à peine
plus âgés mais déjà un mandat derrière
lui ugo bernalicis brief une dernière
fois le jeune député insoumis avant sa
première intervention en séance de toute
façon faut pas oublier qu'on peut
laisser de la place en première
intention à celui qui défend
l'amendement hier la réponse
je resterai de faire une distance
derrière et du coup c'est nous de la
commission souvent qu'ils ont la
deuxième lame parce qu'on a suivi les
débats bien sûr c'est comme ça qu'on l'a
fonctionne ici pendant cinq ans des
copains sur des textes on avait suivi
avec daniel pour le pass il faisait là
sa première intention et nous on verra
demain ok
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard
c'est le grand saut
madame la ministre collègues pour ma
première intervention dans cette
assemblée qu'il me soit permis dans
l'hémicycle antoine le moment à trouver
sa place au milieu des bandes et un sol
humide
plus efficace pour sa première prise de
parole la main tremble un peu de talent
et de débit wifi 14h dans les lieux
publics commencer par les écoles pour
protéger nos enfants battez-vous à l'om
c'est pour obtenir la levée ou l'oeil
bienveillant et les encouragements du
hautbert mairie 6 mai le nouveau député
est en phase d'apprentissage schveizer
biotech et compagnie effectivement je
tremblais un petit peu c'était un moment
un peu stressant on va se reprendre
c'est le one shot comme on dit qu'il ya
ce côté très impressionnant de
l'assemblée nationale parlait dans
l'assemblée nationale pour les gens
comme moi c'est un honneur
donc ouais il ya ce côté très émouvant
on a toujours peur de dire une bêtise on
se dit ah là là il faut prendre la
parole mais si je dis une bêtise je vais
être directement affichées dessus donc
un petit côté stressant
justin grue est aussi va faire ses
premières armes en séance publique elle
a obtenu de poser une des questions au
gouvernement au nom de son groupe l'est
républicain
on va dire que je suis concentré j'ai
bien travaillé mais idée clef pour
interpeller monsieur le ministre de
l'économie ça me semble important de
m'affirmer aussi dans l'hémicycle et je
suis contente que le groupe mais fait
confiance pour pouvoir porter cette
notion de prix du carburant sur le
pouvoir d'achat l'an
dernier regard sur ces notes avant
l'hémicycle
revenons un tarif raisonnable des
carburants
nous faisons des propositions pour
financer ces mesures
notamment par des économies importantes
dans le fonctionnement bien trop lourd
de nos administrations monsieur mines un
trou d oeil sur le chronomètre qui tout
en mesurant ne doit pas être réservé à
ces deux minutes d'intervention voyez
dans votre elle a tenu le timing sans
être coupés la députée peut souffler un
peu stressé quand même au moment où il
faut commencer à parler un peu frustré
aussi en fait parce qu'on aurait envie
de prendre le temps de répondre d'avancé
plus d'arguments et on est vite limité
par le temps mais c'est le jeu de
l'exercice c'est comme ça l'expérience
va faire que je serai de plus en plus à
l'aise mais pour une première ça s'est
plutôt bien passé mais
après ses premiers pas en commission
frédéric valletoux at il fait le bon
choix en lâchant son mandat de maire
pour celui de député
finalement je regrette pas le choix que
j'ai fait d'abord donné ma mairie je
n'avais pas anticipé bien sûr résultats
l'élection mais je regrette pas parce
que je plonge dans un endroit où
effectivement aujourd'hui on sent que
c'est là que se fait la politique et ça
c'est intéressant
faire passer ses idées se positionner
sur des textes de loi et surtout trouver
des compromis
chacun de ces quatre députés a
maintenant cinq ans pour faire ses
preuves à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]